are you angry Mr President that Ron
DeSantis entered the race
there's loyal person because he was dead
he was looking for jobs and I endorsed
him and he went up many points he was 30
points then at least maybe more than
that he was dead so I think he's very
disloyal but I don't care look Paul just
came out in Iowa he saw the one that
just came out a little couple of minutes
ago I'm leading by
30 or 40 points
uh I don't mind that at all but no I
think he's very disloyal but he's got no
personality if you don't have
personality politics is a very hard
business so Hey listen I actually agree
with this analysis desantis's
personality is just so uh the opposite
of what anybody would ever want to see
at a dinner party or in the in the Oval
Office
um that I I it's obviously it's not just
that he's also a dangerous authoritarian
wannabe I think Trump is actually right
about that